[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Hamilton
New Jersey Natalie is on the line hi
Natalie how are you hi I'm good how are
you better than I deserve what's
up okay so me and my husband were we
were on baby step 2 for a while and then
we went back to baby step one um ever
since 2019 we like bought a house and
then we ended up getting cars CU our
cars were falling apart and um we were
having a baby and all that stuff so
anyway when we bought the house they
said we needed to get a new roof within
the next year or two and that was 2019
so now it's 2023 and we need a new roof
and it's going to be like $7,000 and we
don't have anything saved for it and
we're trying to figure out do Stu yeah
yeah like we told you not to buy a house
while you're in debt and you did it
anyway no yeah pretty much I pretty much
you're dead me and my husband are on
different we my husband doesn't have the
same mindset as me
um so where yeah so where's his money
for the roof he didn't have it with his
mindset does he no yeah it's not
working no so $7,000 roof the roof
leaking it's not leaking it looks okay
so far how much debt have you
got um well not including the mortgage
we have like
109,000 on
what and that is mostly student loans
it's 80,000 in student loans
um 20,000 between our two cars um and
then 5,000 in credit card and what's
your household
income um per month it's about like
9,000 okay so about 120,000 a year after
taxes and everything take it out
okay I can't help you until you guys
decide you're ready to change your lives
yeah I kind of think you are because I
kind of hear fear in your
voice I think you're
scared because he because he's continued
to not change and you all keep doing the
same stupid butt stuff over and over
don't you yeah and we use we um we
budget every month but it's like every
month set aside thing yeah it doesn't
doesn't follow through no it's it's a
wish it's a dream you're not you're not
really leaning in the two of you have
not sat down taken each other's hands
and look deeply into each other's eyes
and says nothing happens here till we
get this debt cleaned up we're about to
be on beans and rice rice and beans and
we're going to clean up we're going to
quit buying anything until we get this
debt cleaned up and we're going to live
on nothing and we're going to make every
dollar scream every dollar is going to
behave you all are nowhere near
that yeah you wish you were but you're
not yeah yeah yeah so what what what
what is going to get him moving in the
right direction you have the money to
clean this up once you have the once you
have the will
yeah um I did sit down with him like
actually a couple days ago and I
actually finally listed out like all the
debts that we had and like and we you
know figured out like okay the de if we
did the debt snowball we'd like pay it
off within like five years just paying
the minimums and doing the debt snowball
yeah so you would be Deb you you should
be debt free in about two and a half
years yeah if we really if you did what
I teach you to
do you have the money to do it you don't
have the will to do it what did he say
when he saw this pad and his wife
terrified sitting in front of him yeah
well yeah it's almost like it's
laughable because it's I mean it's not
funny but it's like because we're just
like we knew the student loan debt was
bad um and that's what when you lay it
out and say I can do it in two and a
half years if I would commit to it like
an adult and quit being a child what's
laughable it's not laughable it's very
doable it's not yeah it's very doable um
why why are what's holding you guys up
from doing
that I just I don't know every year
every month it's like I feel like our
gift budget goes is crazy every month
we're like because we have so many
family and friends and and weddings and
baby shower has nothing to do with it
has nothing to do with it no I know yeah
you know what it
is the two of you are not working
together you don't agree that you have
to sacrifice deeply for two and a half
years to clean up this mess once you
agree to that the gift budget goes away
we just tell people no I can't do it I'm
broke I'm so broke I can't put a roof on
my own freaking house of course I'm not
buying you a
gift I mean it's real simple did he
resist it when you laid out the the
debts for him what was his reaction you
didn't answer that no no he he was
actually on board he said yeah like that
sounds good but it's just a matter of
like well now we have that but then we
also have to get a roof so how are we
going to afford because we can't wait
you don't have to get a roof it's not
leaking it's just looking like it's
going to leak that's right yeah the roof
is not your problem mhm the problem is
you make $99,000 a month and you keep
buying crap you can't afford like a
roof yeah you can't you need to clean
this mess up and you'll be able to get a
roof you'll be able to get a roof roofs
you can get a roof but the two of you
need to get on a detailed budget
together and deeply sacrifice cut
everything out of your lives no eating
out no vacations certainly no buying
anything it's not necessary to exist
scorched Earth lifestyle and $9,000 a
month you can clean up a lot of debt on
that kind of money you got a good income
but you just misbehave with it
continuously and you guys are going to
have to fix that when you fix that the
stuff we teach with every dollar
Financial Peace University Total Money
Makeover book it works and you'll be
able to do it but you're still not there
that's key folks I hope you heard what
Dave said because we as humans we want
to fit in we want to do whatever it
takes to make everybody happy and the
gifts is not the reason they're in the
ho they in but it is the reason why they
haven't decided to make change yet
they're more willing to be uncomfortable
and deal with with financial Stress and
Anxiety and not being able to the roof
to be able to do this this this this and
this things that don't really matter and
that's what happens you've got to get to
a point where you go none of this other
stuff matters anymore it still matters
too much until you say I've had it which
you've said many times on stage and in
our FPU videos but until you get there
you won't make the change yeah it it's
just it's that way for everybody it's
kind of it's kind I'm I've be kind of
smart I like with her but it's sad it
sure is it's really sad cuz the stress
you can hear it in her voice oh and um
and so that goes away when you get on a
detailed plan and you commit but you
have to reach the point that you don't
care what other people think that's
right the only thing that matters is you
and your husband on one page the kids
don't get a vote your mama don't get get
a vote nobody gets a vote and we're
cleaning up this mess we're not buying
anything else until we get this dad gum
mess cleaned up I'm tired of living with
my stomach in my throat I'm sick and
tired of being sick and tired when you
reach that point you will do what it
takes to win